- [Instructor] This is a chart
that shows the percentage
of the total population
of each of these colonies,
and then later, states,
that was made up by enslaved Africans.
Starting in the year 1754,
which we'll show in purple,
and comparing that to the year 1800,
which we'll show here in green.
Now some of these numbers are estimates,
since the census didn't exist before 1790,
but this can help us get an overall sense
of how the institution of slavery
changed in these years.
Now on the left side here,
we have the data from the Northern part
of the country.
Now in purple you can see
the percentage of the population
of each colony that was enslaved in 1754,
and generally, it wasn't
a very large amount,
think New York here had
the most at about 14%.
By 1800, however, you can see that
the percent went down considerably.
Some, like Massachusetts,
outlawed slavery altogether,
so they're at 0%,
and others like New York or Rhode Island,
began a process of gradual emancipation,
phasing out slavery.
Another thing to note is that
new territories in the West
that were claimed by the United States
either had very small amounts of slavery,
like in the Indiana
Territory, or none at all,
like in the Northwest Territory,
where slavery was outlawed.
Now let's compare that to the same period
in Southern Regions.
In most of the South in 1754,
enslaved people made up
a very significant
portion of the population.
In some cases, like in South Carolina,
outnumbering whites at
a rate of more than 60%
of the population.
And unlike in the North,
as you see here in teal,
in 1800, enslaved people remained
a really quite large percentage
of the population.
In some cases, the percent of people
who were enslaved grew considerably,
like in Delaware or in Georgia,
and in other places stayed about the same.
In places like Virginia
and South Carolina,
the percent of the
population that was enslaved
actually dropped over this time period,
but not because there were fewer slaves,
but rather because the white population
had grown faster than
the enslaved population
in the same time period.
And unlike in the Northern Territories,
the percentage of enslaved people
in the new Southern Territories
claimed by the United States,
Kentucky, Tennessee, Mississippi,
was quite significant as well.
So what's happening here?
Why, over this 50 year period,
did slavery begin to die out in the North,
while surviving, and even expanding West,
in the South?
How much change was there
over this time period
in the regional attitudes about slavery?
And how would we even go
about figuring that out?
One way that we can attempt
to measure the extent of change
is by identifying the
things that stayed the same
during this time period,
which we call Continuities,
or aspects of society that continued on
being the same as they were before,
and Changes, aspects of society
that were different than before.
There are many different
aspects of society
that historians can trace changes
and continuities in over time,
like changes in politics
or art or gender roles,
but for this video,
I'm gonna choose Economics and Ideas.
Why am I choosing those two?
Well, first and foremost,
because slavery was an economic practice.
It was a source of labor
that supported the production
of agricultural products.
Second, I know that in this time period,
the American Revolution
introduced radical changes
in ideas about Liberty and Equality,
which stand in stark contrast
to the institution of slavery.
So let's compare the Economic systems
and Ideas about slavery
in each of these Regions,
in 1754 and 1800, to see what changed
and what stayed the same.
So first, let's look at
the Economic systems.
In the North, where the
climate and the soil
was not suited for large scale
plantation agriculture,
the economy centered around
family farms in 1754.
Proximity to the coast facilitated fishing
and shipping,
and the people who actually did this work
tended to be either
the owners of the farms
or the boats, or indentured servants,
and a small number of enslaved laborers
who worked for them.
None of these activities really required
the labor of a large
number of enslaved people.
All right, well, what about in 1800?
Farming and fishing and shipping
were still going strong,
but as the first Industrial Revolution
began to take off in the late 1700s,
factories began to spring up in the North,
and the cheapest labor
source for these factories
was immigrant laborers,
not slaves, not indentured servants.
Now let's look at the Economic systems
of the South in 1754 and 1800.
In 1754, plantation agriculture
based on enslaved labor
was the central economic
system, and it was also
the central economic system in 1800.
But unlike in the North,
where the technological innovations
of the Industrial Revolution
made indentured servants
or enslaved laborers unnecessary,
the major technological innovation
of the cotton gin
made cotton easier to process,
and therefore, saved it
as a profitable crop,
which made slave owners eager to expand
the institution of slavery,
rather than phase it out.
Next, let's take a look at the ideas
about slavery, which were commonly held
in each of the regions.
In 1754 in the North,
I would say a few people questioned
the existence of slavery.
Northern Shipping was involved
in the Atlantic Slave Trade.
The idea that masters
deserve to rule slaves
was as natural as the idea
that kings deserve to rule their subjects.
Even free people of color
were rarely considered
full British citizens,
the way people of English descent were.
How did things change in 1800?
The Revolutionary War had a strong effect
on the ideas about slavery in the North.
Northerners apply the Revolutionary ideals
of Liberty and Equality
to long-standing ideas about social rules,
and they found that slavery
was incompatible with them.
So after the Revolution, Northern States
either abolished slavery
or began to phase it out
with gradual emancipation.
But I wanna caution you
into thinking that this
turned the North into
a racial utopia.
People of African descent
were still not permitted
to become American citizens,
even though the immigrants,
who were beginning to
flood in from Europe were.
So I think it would be
fair to say overall,
that the North had never
really needed slavery,
and therefore, when
the Revolution led many
to question the institution of slavery,
it was pretty easy to abolish it.
How does that compare to
the South's transition
in this time period?
Well, by 1754, the notion that
slavery was natural
and enslaved Africans were property
was pretty well-ingrained.
But the ideas of the Revolution
didn't have quite the
same effect on the South
as they did in the North.
If anything, by 1800, white Southerners
were determined to enact
harsher slave codes than ever
because they feared uprisings,
since the ideals of
the American Revolution
had inspired the Haitians
to overthrow the French.
So why did these changes
in continuities over time matter?
Well, because by 1800, you start to see
attitudes around slavery crystallizing
in the United States,
creating a North where slavery was rare
and considered a perversion of the ideals
of the Revolution,
and a South where slavery was central
and considered natural
and perhaps even a desirable way
to organize society.
And as white settlers
from each of these regions
moved farther and farther West,
into territories that were opened up
by the American victory
in the Revolutionary War
and by Indian removal,
both Northerners and Southerners
would export their Economic systems
and their ideas about slavery
into these adjacent Western lands.
By 1820, this gradual process
would erupt into Sectional
crisis over slavery.